مشاهدينا ينضم الينا عبر زوم من جنديرس
خليل شامس وادي زوج عمه الطفله التي ولدت
تحت الانقاض وقريبها للتفكير فقط مشاهدينا
الطفله التي وصفت بالطفله المعجزه والتي
ولدت تحت الانقاض والتي يعني عمت وكل
العالم تحدث عنها خليل يعني اليوم السؤال
الاساسي كيف هي الطفله هل هي بصحه جيده
واين هي الان
التخصصي وهي بحاله جيده وهي كلها اشاعات
يعني
واخبار ما في من هالحكي هذا خالص ليش ما
تم اخدا للمنزل حتى الساعه
الاطمئنان على صحتها اكثر ونحن الان نقوم
باجراءات قضائيه وقمنا بالتحليل دي ان ايه
من اجل
صله القرابه طبعا هذه هذه التحاليل هذه
التحاليل طلبت من جهات مختصه ومسؤوله في
المنطقه وبالتالي انتم اليوم يعني عم
تقومون بالتدابير والاجراءات لتسجيل رسميا
على اسمك
ونعم تبنيها نعم
على اسمك استاذ خليل يعني هل هناك هناك
بعض الاخبار التي تتحدث عن خلاف بالعائله
على تبني هذه الفتاه هل هناك اي احد من
العائله يحق له تبني الفتاه
لا لا ما في بالعكس انا
عندي وراح تكون وحده من اولادي يعني ما في
فرق ان شاء الله وراح تكون اغلى من ولادي
كمان طيب يعني كل القصص كل القصص التي
سمعناها بالساعات الماضيه عن محاوله خطفها
عن محاوله الاتجار فيها كل هذا ما هي
فيلا اشاعات وانا اشكر الجهات المختصه
الشرطه والكذا الاقامه بحمايتها اكثر
والجيش الوطني كامل يعني بحمايتها من
بحمايتها بحمايتها من ماذا هي طفله اعربت
منذ الساعات الاولى بانك يعني تريد تبنيها
وهي بالمستشفى يتم علاجها حمايتها من ماذا
من
اشياء الاخبار النظام السوري حاول
وانه هي بمناطقم وكذا
النظام يحاول خطفه ام انه اشخاص يحاولون
خطفها لبيع
هو اللي يحاول
بده بالمصاري طبعا
شكرا لك استاذ خليل شامي السوادي زوج عمه
الطفله التي ولدت تحت الانقاض ان نتمنى
يعني ان تتم رعايتها رعايه جيده جدا لانها
فعلا طفله